Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Today we're going to talk about dehydration and more specifically different blood values
that could give us a pattern to tell a story about possible dehydration.
We can't omit the fact that some people become dehydrated from overhydrated.
It's not very common, but it is becoming more common, especially when people are carried around big water jugs
and I've had people say that they drink gallons of water every day, about 150 pounds or something like that
and you're probably drinking too much water. You can overhydrate and overhydrate and flushes out your electrolytes.
You need electrolytes to hold water in the tissues and you actually become dehydrated by overhydrated.
So be careful about that as well. A person also can think that they're perfectly hydrated.
They drink a lot of fluids every day, but they might be drinking fluids that are causing losses of minerals
and causing losses of fluid. Let's say you're drinking a lot of caffeine.
So a lot of caffeine drinks a day with other drinks that are not caffeinated can cause dehydration as well,
even though you think you're consuming enough fluids.
But we'll look at blood values that can cause that, but you also want to look at symptoms.
So obviously this is going to be more common in the summertime when a person is sweating most common causes of dehydration
are a person maybe didn't eat because a loss, a decrease amount of nutrients that are circulated in the blood
is specifically minerals in the tissues will cause you to have a more difficult time holding your water.
So if you're if you've fasted for some reason, you just didn't eat breakfast, didn't eat anything for supper last night,
you weren't hungry, you went out in the garden, it worked all day and it's 99 degrees outside and you're sweating profusely.
You can easily become dehydrated. Obviously you think of I'm thirsty, I have a dry mouth,
but other things you can become faint, a person can lose consciousness.
Muscle cramps are probably one of the most common scenarios with dehydration.
But you'll notice signs like a darker color urine.
You can get a darker color urine from taking B vitamins, but if why didn't take any B vitamins?
And I have a much darker color urine that is concerned for dehydration.
So there's some things that you just want to look at.
Now there are some signs in your blood work that do give us clues to dehydration as well.
Now typically somebody's not going to go in for normal blood work and they're feeling well and they're going to be told, hey, you're dehydrated.
Usually these tests are going to show positive when a person is brought to the hospital because they fainted outside and then they're in the ER and they're running these blood tests.
Well, this is what you're going to see on the blood tests.
So this is a dehydration pattern.
Short term dehydration, you're going to have an increase in hemoglobin.
Well, that's the opposite of an edemia.
So with an edemia, you're going to have a decrease hemoglobin, a decrease hematic ret.
A decrease red blood cell count.
But with dehydration, you're going to have an increase of those.
And truly it's really a relative increase because you have a decrease water in the blood.
Therefore, it's going to be a concentration of hemoglobin and red blood cells showing a relative increase in hemoglobin because that's what it's going to show in the blood test.
You're going to have a relative increase in sodium and potassium as well.
And then long term dehydration, you're going to have an increase in albiment.
This dehydration is probably really one of the only things that are really going to show an increase in albiment in the blood.
So when you see an increase in albiment, you know that there's dehydration going on.
Now this can be a pattern with people with chronic disease as well.
And you have to watch this pattern with people that have a chronic disease, let's say stage 4 cancer.
And they've had a noticeable decrease in hemoglobin, a decrease in hematic ret and red blood cell.
They're in a state of anemia of chronic disease.
But then you see a bump up of that.
So it still might be decreased on the blood work.
But from the last test a month ago, that has bumped up.
Well, that's a good side, right?
Well, yes, we hope so.
But if you also notice an increase in albiment, an increase in bun BUN and an increase in total serum protein,
you have to be concerned, is this person really there anemia getting better?
That's improving.
Or are we seeing dehydration patterns that are taking place?
So you want to keep an eye on that as well.
So again, if the person has a history of anemia, especially anemia of chronic disease,
would you think of like a stage 4 cancer person and their hemoglobin, hematic ret and red blood cell count
and other red blood cell CBC markers have been decreased, showing an anemia pattern over a period of months.
And then you notice it bump up.
It's not always a good thing.
You have to look at other patterns in this showing dehydration because with people in that state,
it's not uncommon that they're not drinking.
So they are experiencing patterns of dehydration, but it's missed because they have such serious anemia going on.
So look at the pattern changes.
This is another reason why it's important to do regular blood work.
It's never just one test.
You know, unless it's in the acute emergency situation, it's a pattern that you want to look for.
Well, what's the care for this?
You need to rehydrate, obviously, unless your anemia is caused from overhydration, which is less common,
but you need to make sure the person is drinking.
You also need to be adding minerals.
And even glucose sugar is important in this scenario.
You need to build the blood back up.
So just drinking water is typically not enough.
You need to add minerals.
You need to add glucose.
And I suggest a good quality mineral.
I see too many times people are using these liquid minerals.
I'm not afraid of those.
Or just poor quality minerals that you might buy or at your pharmacy.
Make sure that when you look at the back of your minerals,
and I do have a video just on proper purchase seed of different minerals.
When you look at the back of your bottle of minerals,
you should see this thing where it says calcium,
but it says as tracks, T-R-A-A-C-S, calcium by glycidate, keylate.
Tracks is a company that makes, so tracks in Albion are the companies that make minerals
that are double bonded to an amino acid, just exactly the way that you would get your minerals
if you ate a plant.
The minerals that you see, that we see a lot of people taking liquid minerals,
those are ionic minerals.
That is not how we're supposed to be consuming minerals.
We're supposed to be consuming minerals by eating plants or eating grass-fed animals.
Those are going to be double bonded minerals, double bonded to amino acids.
That's how we're supposed to consume minerals.
That's how they're going to get into the cells, not in the ionic form,
which is similar to eating dirt.
We don't know if it's supposed to eat dirt, God didn't make us to eat dirt.
He made us to eat plants.
Plants take ionic minerals, convert them into double bonded to an amino acid.
This is how we should be taking our minerals.
So make sure you take a good quality mineral.
All right, thanks for this short video,
and we'll see you in the next video.